which looks like a royal mess doesn't it
okay
but then again we should kind of expect
it to look like a royal mess because we
don't have
all the pieces that we need for this
right we're missing the time piece
we're missing the timepiece so how would
we get that how we go about getting some
time into here instead of all of these
uh k's and
way too many g's that should be there
okay
so i'm gonna go back i'm gonna go back
to this line
okay as you'll see shortly this line is
critical right instead of writing it as
v dv
on d x i'm going to write it as d v on
dt that'll get me t's
right so i'll say dv on dt
this turns out to be farther strenuous
actually okay
is equal to g minus kv what should i do
turn it upside down
then i can integrate
okay so this is a much nicer need to log
the kinds of things they're more
familiar with
right you're going to get time is equal
to negative 1 on k
plus a constant yes what does the
constant work out to be
you can work that out as well right
it's like log g something something like
like this right
from the initial conditions
is that right does that square people
there yep
okay so again just like before i can put
this together with my log laws and you
get something that looks suddenly very
familiar
right you get uh let's see a factor of
one arabic
a at the front oops don't need that yeah
log off
and you're like oh hold on hold on hold
on look at this look at this it's right
there
you see this is how that tee just
magically appears out of nowhere
okay so this is really good even though
we're not accustomed to having time as a
function of velocity
usually at this point we would rearrange
stuff you know multiply by k
and get velocity as a function of time
we don't need that we're not getting
towards a velocity equation
okay so i'm just going to leave it there
right
one last piece okay here if you lost
track
here's the first piece piece number one
is
x as a function of v piece number two
is t as a function of v have a look at
the result you are trying to prove
what's missing
what am i not accounted for and think
about what we started that looking at
this morning
very first thing
i don't have anything in what i've
worked on that talks at all
about terminal velocity right i haven't
brought that into play that's my third
and final piece
how do i find terminal velocity how do i
do it
terminal velocity occurs when
a is equal to 0. that's all so i'm going
to come back to this guy
again right and say well therefore
g minus k no longer little b
that's a variable right i'm interested
in terminal velocity
right that's going to be equal to zero
that's the acceleration
okay so you rearrange a little bit let's
see
k v equals g so v
equals g on k
finally here's my third piece
terminal velocity so it looks to me like
i'm gonna put this
and this into here you see that
two and three into one might even write
that down so
two and three into
one okay really helps so you don't get
lost in all of the different equations
that you've just formed
okay um the two is really easy to see
isn't it
you can see it right there okay so in
fact if i just
tease this out a little bit
i'm going to have g over k
times 1 over k is that okay
so there you can see right there that's
the that's time
okay so uh i need more space
is this gonna be enough space yeah
that'll be enough space
so now i'm doing my substitution i've
got x is equal to
okay let's see g over
k times time
right and then you've got
minus v over k hanging out over there
okay i'm getting really close now you
can see how close i am
i need to bring in the terminal velocity
how will i do that
i need a few more g over k's in there
because that's what the terminal
velocity is
right and when you look at this final
line oh look i don't want
x actually i want g x so i'm going to
multiply everything through by gravity
okay gravitational constant i should say
like so right so now you can see the two
spots where terminal velocity
can be subbed in where g over k can be
summed in right there there's one
the uh i read the big v first didn't i
v v there's one
and then there's another one in here but
you've got next to gravity that's okay
v g t
gx so now what do i have to do i just
have to keep this guy over
and we're there okay
take a deep breath
so what was interesting in this question
the first thing was
you had to get these two variables in
there which is weird but totally doable
totally doable it means it meant that we
took two different forms
of the acceleration equation right and
we used them both to get to these two
parts you also had to bring in a total
velocity in this way and then you can
just
sub it in wherever it's necessary okay